[Music]
julia's in iowa city iowa to start off
this hour hi julia how are you
i'm so good hi you guys thank you for
taking my call i am like your biggest
fan okay well we're honored how can we
help
okay i'm a little nervous um
i'm 23 years old
i work as a nurse and i'm currently on
baby steps four five and six
um i plan to start travel nursing here
in august
just in hopes to increase my income and
learn a bit more
um my question for you guys is
um should i think about buying a house
or a condo
to rent out while i travel nurse or
should i just wait on that
i'd wait
yeah okay you're 23 you got time
one thing about travel nursing that we
know is you're gonna pile up a big pile
of money while you're doing this
yeah i hope so with that pile of money
you might make a different purchase than
you would make today
okay yeah and uh also uh
renting what you know dealing with
tenants while you don't live in the town
because you're running around all over
the place
can uh leave you pretty vulnerable to a
mess
uh-huh
it might get like a property manager
like i'm just i'm just kidding well i
mean it's okay to have a property
manager but let me just tell you that
there's one thing you got to know about
real estate
it all sounds good until you actually
are doing it
yeah and when you're actually doing it
there's blood and guts and
cat pee in the living room i mean it's
just there's stuff you deal with that's
real
and um i've owned real estate for 40
years and i love real estate but people
that have not owned rental real estate
or that are all enamored with getting
rich in real estate
have not figured out that it is a lot of
stuff to deal with
i've got a property management company
that i own
that manages my properties and i'm still
asked questions almost every day
walked by one of them's desk a while ago
and she stopped me and said hey what
about this with this tenant and and i'm
not even doing the day-to-day management
but she was just wanting to know because
it was a large situation so you know
you're just gonna everything's a large
situation here you're adding hassle to
your life i would keep my life clean
and pile up some money yeah especially
if you're traveling my my guess is
you're going to go to some city or some
state and you're going to love it and
you're going to wish you weren't
tethered down somewhere else
that could happen yeah you could get the
itch to relocate
when this is all done and because you're
going to see some cool places that's one
of the benefits of doing what i've done
all these years i've gotten to see
america's great cities
and and love them i mean there's a lot
of really cool places to live in america
i do it there are some armpits in
america last year i was on the road more
than i've ever been and yeah there's
some
places i've never been to incredible
beautiful places
all over the country and there's other
people places you go and you go why does
humans live here i remember thinking
this place looks like beirut you all
know we can choose you can live wherever
you want to and
that's cool whatever yeah it's yeah but
yeah it's it's there's a lot of fun out
there that we had and
a lot of adventure to be had go have
that okay